today we're making homemade pasta
Northwest and Selena Gomez's little
sister Gracie teefy are the cutest
besties on Tick Tock hanging out and
casually making pasta I don't know
what's gonna top that the BFF shared a
series of videos to North's join account
with her mom Kim Kardashian over the
weekend walking viewers through the
steps of making noodles from scratch
step one get Glam I mean come on this is
Kim Kardashian's daughter people
next up lots of flour and lots and lots
and lots of eggs
now we have to move on to the next step
please
[Music]
Gracie who cut the dough into strips
after North rolled out the mixture
shared this wasn't her first time making
pasta
yeah
you heard that right she had a hashtag
kitchen fail with North's cousin
Kourtney Kardashian's daughter Penelope
Disick and while the girls didn't film
the final product they did serve up some
moments of impromptu singing and
silliness
and take it slowly North also dished on
her favorite singers which naturally
included her famous dad Kanye West I'm
just extremely happy can you tell by my
face
[Music]
that sells little sis and pee delivering
some custom-made slime to North oh my
goodness yeah Gracie also made a cameo
on Penelope's account getting a makeover
to look just like her bestie of course
Gracie has been in plenty of tick tocks
with her Superstar sis too together
best friend she's awesome she's just
there to have a good time I don't think
my sister overthinks anything and that's
what I love about her North and Gracie's
pasta hang comes just days after fans
speculated there's drama between
Northeast Aunt Kylie Jenner and Selena
it all went down last week after Selena
posted this clip to tick tock
referencing her newly done brows I
accidentally laminated my brows too much
shortly after that Kylie posted this
snap writing this was an accident over
her brows before sharing a close-up pic
of her pal Haley Bieber's brows you know
the model who's married to Justin Bieber
whom Selena dated on and off for years
after people online started to debate if
Kylie and Haley were throwing shade at
cell the beauty Mogul slid into the
comments to slam the suggestion that her
post was about the only murders in the
building star you guys are making
something out of nothing this is silly
yes I can't Selena responded directly to
Kylie's comment to agree writing I'm a
fan of Kylie Selena later announced
during a tick tock live that she's on a
break from social media this is a little
silly
and I'm 30. I'm too old for this so but
over on Instagram we're still getting
plenty of cute sister moments check out
this pick Selena's account shared
Thursday fishing with Gracie writing
grateful thankful and blessed ladies
foreign